you've kind of called your philosophy
rational buddhism how does that differ
from traditional buddhism and what type
of exploration did you go through to
arrive at that
yeah the rational part means that i have
to reconcile with science and evolution
so
and i have to reject all the pieces that
i can't verify for myself so for example
is meditation good for you yes just
clearing your mind a good thing yes is
there a base layer of awareness kind of
below your monkey mind yes all these
things i verified for myself and some of
the beliefs that come out of buddhism
i believe and follow because again i've
verified or reasoned
with thought experiments there myself
but what i will not accept is things
that are written down as just so like oh
you're this in the past lives that
you're paying off the karma for well i
haven't seen it i don't remember any
past lives i don't have any memory so i
just have to not believe that or when
people say you know your third chakra is
opening and your second chakra is i
don't know this is fancy nomenclature
right i have not been able to verify or
confirm any of that on my own so if i
can't verify it on my own or if i cannot
get there through science then i just
then it may be true it may be false but
it's not falsifiable so i cannot view it
as a fundamental truth
on the other side i do know that
evolution is true i do know that we are
uh you know evolve survival and
replication machines
i do know that we have an ego so that we
get up off the ground and worms don't
eat us we actually take action
so what rational buddhism to me means
understanding the the internal work that
buddhism espouses to make yourself
happier and better off and more present
and more in control of your emotions and
being a better human being
but
i don't subscribe to anything fanciful
just because it was written down in a
book
i don't think i can levitate i don't
think that meditation is going to give
me superpowers and those kinds of things
so it's you know it's basically
uh try everything test it for yourself
be skeptical uh keep what's useful and
discard what's not um so i would say my
philosophy falls down too and on one
pole is evolution
as a binding principle because it
explains so much about humans
and on their side is buddhism which is
the oldest most time-tested spiritual
philosophy
on the internal state of being inside
each of us
and i think those are absolutely
reconcilable i actually want to write a
blog post at some point about how you
can map the tenets of buddhism
especially the non-sensible ones
directly into a virtual reality
simulation what i mean by that is if you
believe we're living in a vr sim which i
know some people are spousing
or if you believe the buddhist view of
the world with samsara and nirvana and
all that you would actually come to the
same conclusions on how to live your
life
[Music]
[Music]
you